europe's leaders gathered in brussels
hidden by masks
chatting about brexit there was no deal
signed here
nor much sign that one's on the way the
only real progress
a willingness to keep talks going into
november we
are absolutely determined to reach a
fair deal
with the uk we will do
everything we can but not
at any price mr barnier's boss
had arrived earlier talking about
europe's biggest problem
there are crucial topics on the agenda
first of all of course covet the
situation is getting
more and more worrisome and
strong action is needed not long after
she proved her own point
wonderland was rushed away to
self-isolate
a member of her team had tested positive
for coronavirus
so there has been plenty of talk about a
potential brexit deal over there
in the european council today but look
also at what's happened in the margins
emmanuel macron saying that he wouldn't
sacrifice his fishermen in pursuit of a
brexit
deal while ursula fond de lion has gone
into
self-isolation pretty symbolic evidence
that european politicians have focused
much more on covid
than they are on brexit so can a deal be
done
the dutch prime minister told me he was
cautiously optimistic
i believe we all have an enormous
interest of achieving a deal
of course europe but also the uk both
because of our economic situation
but as i said last time also because of
the geopolitical
situation but in a tweet britain's chief
negotiator was down beat
lord frost writing disappointed by the
european council conclusions on
uk eu negotiations surprised eu is no
longer committed to working
intensively to reach a future
partnership as agreed with ursula fonda
lion
on 3rd of october there was an
anti-brexit protest here today but we
know the uk
is leaving the eu the question is how
progress towards the deal has been
painfully slow and boris johnson is now
mulling whether to persist with these
talks
or bring them to an end adam parsons sky
news brussels